Sở y tế thành phố của chính mình cho biết từ ngày 1,5 năm, hành hình không chẳng hành mi sấu,
sẽ có sáo nhóm đối tượng đặt thủ sẽ được thành phố của chợt vàn dịt mức nóng bảo hiệp y tế.
Chí sẽ mở này, có phần cùng cố mạng nơi an sĩ sả hội, bao đảng quyền lợi trong sof sức quẻ trong người dân trên địa bản thành phố.
Thành phố của chính mình sẽ mở giậu dịt bảo phủ bảo hiệp y tế cho sáo nhóm đối tượng đặt thủ gồm.
Người bệnh phong đang điều chỉ tại bệnh biệt biệt biệt sáng, thuật sở y tế.
Chẻ em đội tuổi từ đủ sấu đến dưới người sáo tuổi có đăng kỹ thường chú hoặc cạm chú tạc thỉc phố.
Bình kẹn đó, còn có hộ nèo và cận nèo theo chuẩn nhau đá chều của địa phương.
Người mới thắt nèo trong bọng bà người sảo tháng kể thực khi có quyết định cơm nhận thật nèo.
Người cào tuổi từ sống mười đến dưới sống 1 làm tuổi, các trường hợp sống đơn thân đặc thân có thu nhập thất hơn chuẩn nhau đá chều thật quy định.
Người mới bệnh hiểm nhau và người quyết tạc nhẹ về tị giác có thu nhập thấp hơn chuẩn nhau đá chều và có đăng kỹ cư chú tạc thỉc phố.
Những người thuộc dịt trên được hỗ trợ 1 trăm phần chạm mức đáu bảo vệ biệt biệt tế.
Tên bộ 1 kịch vi để thực hiện chí sách này được đăng bảo tự lưng sách nhả nước theo phần cấp hiện hành.